After all the smoke settled and all the cool
hand signals were waved, Doctor Stephen Strange
earned his spot as one of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe's best new heroes.
And like in other Marvel movies, we got an
extra helping of heroism in the form of teasers
for future films after the movie's ending.
Put on your Sling Ring as we explore Doctor
Strange's credits scenes.
And just so you don't think we're possessed
by the dark powers of Dormammu, here's our
warning: there are major spoilers ahead.
Thor's Doctor visit
It's Hammer Time once again as Odin's favorite
son makes a long-awaited return after his
absence from Captain America: Civil War.
The blond brute doesn't look as heroic as
usual when he visits Stephen at his Sanctum.
After getting the Asgardian a giant, magically-refilling
beer, Strange gets down to brass tacks: he
now keeps track of major otherworldly threats
to Earth, which includes Thor's brother Loki,
who has accompanied Thor to New York to look
for their missing daddy, Odin.
For the sake of getting Loki off Earth and
back to Asgard as soon as possible, Strange
decides to help the Odinsons look for their
missing patriarch.
We've still got a lot of questions about what's
happened in Thor's absence,
"Am I disappointed that they didn't invite
me to fight with them?
Um, ha no."
"He doesn't know how to get in touch with
you."
"I don't have a phone."
"He doesn't have a phone!"
...but we have a feeling Thor: Ragnarok will
have answers.
And probably lots of smashing.
"Well they're excited."
Loki's back in town
The last time we saw Loki in Thor: The Dark
World, he was sitting on the throne of Asgard
disguised as Odin, after faking his own death.
Thor didn't seem to notice it was actually
Loki, especially when the "King" offered him
the throne of Asgard, which Thor declined.
He even showed sadness in describing Loki's
death, which shows Loki that Thor still ultimately
cares.
We're not sure what happened after that: Did
Thor see through Loki's disguise?
Did the real Odin contact Thor?
Or, even more crazy: Is it not even Thor at
all, but actually Loki impersonating him to
fool Doctor Strange?
One thing's for sure: the last time Loki was
in New York, things were kind of...bad.
Next time, just take a taxi, dude.
Ragnarok and roll call
Tossing the Sorcerer Supreme into the mix
of Thor: Ragnarok is going to make for some
interesting events.
Considering Marvel has teased that part of
World War Hulk will be mixed into Ragnarok,
we can't wait to see what happens when Doctor
Strange meets Doctor Banner.
"I'm sorry, I'm not that kind of doctor.
I'm not a therapist, it's not my training."
"So."
"I don't have the-"
"What, the time?"
"Temperament."
Ragnarok director Taika Waititi supposedly
played a huge role in the filming of the mid-credits
sequence, so will the Master of the Mystic
Arts throw down with the Hulk?
It's probably worth noting that in the comics,
Strange was one of the people responsible
for exiling the Hulk into space, setting up
the events of the World War Hulk story in
the first place.
Just a stone's throw away...
Thor interacting with Doctor Strange inadvertently
increases the chances of bringing multiple
Infinity Stones together.
For now, Strange leaves the Time Stone-slash-Eye
of Agamotto in Kamar-Taj, which magically
connects to his New York Sanctum.
Likewise, the Space Stone-slash-Tesseract
is now in the vaults of Asgard under heavy
protection.
Putting Strange in Thor's third solo film
moves these Infinity Stones awfully close
together.
The Doc will undoubtedly learn more from Wong
about the Infinity Stones, and there's bound
to be some kind of crazy spell that Strange
could use to find out where the other Stones
are—just to make sure they're all properly
accounted for and in the right hands.
Of course, someone else is on the lookout
for them too…
Thanos on the hunt
Thanos has finally stepped off his floating
throne and started looking for the Infinity
Stones himself...which still seems weird considering
he presumably gave Loki the staff containing
the Mind Stone.
Thor: Ragnarok isn't hitting theaters until
November 3, 2017, and Avengers: Infinity War
is scheduled for May 4, 2018, so this could
be the perfect opportunity for Thanos to start
decorating his golden glove.
Some fans believe Heimdall carries the Soul
Stone in his armor, which explains how he
can see every person in the Nine Realms.
A Thor-Strange team-up could potentially tie
together half of the Stones.
Don't be surprised if the Mad Titan nabs a
few before Infinity War even begins.
Setting up a sequel
Instead of teasing another superhero crossover,
the post-credits scenes established a subplot
that sets up the Sorcerer Supreme's inevitable
sophomore film.
Mordo, the sorcerer who abandoned Doctor Strange
at the end of the film for his abuse of the
Time Stone, visits Jonathan Pangborn.
Pangborn was once paralyzed, but headed overseas
to Kamar-Taj, where he learned how to magically
restore his ability to walk.
Mordo attacks Pangborn, draining him of his
magical powers, and revealing a huge change
in character and a dangerous vendetta.
He's decided that there are just way too many
dang sorcerers bending the rules—so it's
up to him to whittle down their numbers.
He'll inevitably cross paths with the likes
of Wong and Stephen Strange once again.
Mordo the villain
Fans of the printed version of Doctor Strange
knew this switcheroo was coming, despite Mordo
being made into a supportive character throughout
most of the film.
Even when he parts ways with Strange, it's
mostly out of angry disillusionment.
In the comics, Baron Mordo is a longtime antagonist
to Doctor Strange.
Originally a student of the Ancient One, Mordo
tries to kill his master after growing jealous
of Strange becoming a star pupil, leading
to his banishment and pursuit of the black
arts and other forbidden forms of magic in
order to achieve power.
Of course, many of these techniques can backfire,
which is kind of what happened with Kaecilius,
who is originally only a bottom-tier flunky
of Mordo's in the comics.
Despite his change and his crusade against
other sorcerers, it's not like Mordo's gone
fully evil.
He could've simply killed Pangborn if he wanted.
Silencing the sorcerers
Mordo siphoning Pangborn's magical powers
foreshadows his inevitable showdown against
Strange.
His exchange with Pangborn suggests that Mordo
is coming to terms with sorcerers bending
the laws of the universe.
But he likely also believes that he's the
only person responsible enough to do the job.
Mordo is out stealing sorcerers' magic powers
to try and bring things back to normal, and
it should lead up to one heck of a fight in
Doctor Strange 2: Doctor Stranger.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel and watch more videos like
the one you just saw.
And don't forget to check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love, too!